prix augmentent là-bas aussi,
- Ce prix est déjà avantageux
payer dans les villes comme
Magog, Sherbrooke ou Montréal.
Mais traverser la frontière
peut valoir la peine.
AILEY,
résidente de Stanstead
- J'habite à Stanstead,
aussi ici au Vermont, à comme
15 minutes, puis o
chaque semaine ou des fois
plusieurs fois par semaine.
C'est vraiment jus le prix p len
gallon d'essence est de 5,10 $
américain. Ça équivaut à enviro,
ici je vais sauver 20-30 $,
- Avec ce flot de Canadiens qui,
les commerçants du coin font
de bonnes affaires.
- Mon mari est traversé hier
plus tô
l'après-midi. Il y avait une
file d'environ 15 Québécois,
en ligne, juste pour l'essence.
- Le propriétaire de cette
station-service estime que
service estime que
les Québécois sont responsables
d'une augmentation d'environ
le
sentiment d'avoir économisé...
sont amerssont amerssont amersss
de voir le prix à pompeconstamm.
La flam La flam La flam La flae
s'observe à l'échelle mondiale
et est exacerbée par le conf.
Selon des experts, il faudra
attendre encore plusieurs
un frein à la hausse des prix.
Ici Marie-Hélène Rousseau,
Radio-Canada,
à Derby Line, a